pas
[Musique]
dans le cadre de la compétition
nationale de français à madagascar cette
élève du lycée rabearivelo ramamonjy se
sont vu décerner le prix de la meilleure
prestation théâtrale
ils ont été récompensés par un voyage de
découverte culturelle de la réunion
parmi les nombreux partenaires de cette
action le conseil départemental dans ce
concours national malgache sur la
francophonie que ces jeunes qui
réussissent le concours viennent à la
réunion parce que la réunion c'est la
terre française dans l'océan indien
et c'est important aussi qu'ils puissent
voir tous les sites du département qui
sont à leur disposition
dans le cas de de ce concours de la
francophonie
accompagnés de leur professeur de
français les élèves se sont produits sur
scène à la bibliothèque départementale
de la réunion pour présenter la pièce de
théâtre qui les a amenés jusqu'ici
c'était tout un train près pendant à peu
près six mois six mois tu rates de
travail il a fallu qu'ils le montrent le
dimanche
le week end il ne rentre pas midi pour
la répétition pour retravailler
refaçonner tout ça ça n'a pas été facile
pendant une semaine ces lycéens ont eu
la chance de visiter les quatre coins de
l'île son histoire et ses équipements
culturels très remercier tous les
organisateurs
notre quatre heures
les professeurs du lycée dans notre
lycée et je mens je voudrais aussi
remercier les départements
je la réunion et tout ce qui à part sa
participation à l'organisation
le lycée rabearivelo ramamonjy a
remporté la compétition nationale de
france est pour la deuxième année
consécutive
[Musique]